Hello. I am Phil I'm Evan,
and we have a highly anticipated episode of augment out for you today.
That's right. A big shout out to manscape for sponsoring this episode.
Manscaped for people who brought you the lawnmower 3.0,
I know what you're thinking.
Electric braces are annoying because the blades get dull. But guess what?
Manscape also has a replenishment tack, boom,
which comes the new razor sign up every few months.
They will send you a new blade and the slap it on there.
And you'll also get a free gift when you sign up,
which is this handy dandy deodorant deodorant for your foot.
Your not just your foot fill for both feet.
It's just like 20% too expensive for me. Well, funny,
you mentioned it felt simply go to manscape.com/jubilee for 20% off plus free
international shipping apply directly at checkout. No promo code needed. Well,
thank you so much, Evan.
And we hope you enjoy this episode on man.
We brought together seven sorority girls.
I'm in a sorority sorority, I'm in a sorority and I'm in a sorority.
Except everyone is a liar. Like really all of them, they're all lying.
This is odd man out.
So my game plan going in is to give a buddy buddy with one of the girls as quick
as possible. You're like, yes, girl, I'm on your side.
Don't even worry about it. It's important that I like to get the specifics,
right? Because if I can get details early, then they're going to trust me.
I plan on kind of diverting the girl's attention.
Maybe talk more about girly things instead of just green.
But also if I start getting heat or anything like that,
I'm gonna just start pulling everything out of my back pocket because I'm not
going to.
The name that I chose was Marsha. It's close to Martin.
Rachel is a character that I created now.
I think that the sorority for all the information about her chapter,
her sorority philanthropy's state functions, but day.
Uh, I worked on a bunch of notes. You've got everything in here. Uh,
I also did some research about just girls in general, in case, you know,
they try to ask me any questions about girls.
I think a lot of research actually, but that's because like,
this is the first time it's going to be in the bowl.
So of course I'm going to be like, Oh my God, what's going on?
I'm going to have to type like a girl. I'll use the all lower case.
All lower case.
Now I'm going to try and go a little over the top with messages as far as like
how I'm reacting. I know this is my second time to be up and out,
but I am sweating. It's not good.
Just got to not say anything stupid. All right, let's do this.
All right. Round one. Let's go. Let's start with,
I want to do multiple eyes on hi.
I'm not going to be the first one to ask a question.
There's no way that's happening. They'll pick up and I'll just go ahead.
So I'm going to ask where everyone is from. I'm not weak mentally.
Ah, where's everyone from.
I'm in San Jose.
I'm from Missouri state LA,
but go to school at UCS B.
I'm going to capitalize while knocking use proper punctuation. Sona for school.
Oh my gosh, Arizona. That's where Nicole's from.
Nobody's talking. Anything that matters right now,
more takes less testing.
I am a man. I think they're already answering that. Okay.
What sorority is everyone in? Yeah. Obvious question.
Okay. So the first role is you don't ask what sorority you're in. I don't know.
That's just a sorority girl thing, especially when I go out.
So that's kind of a red flag. I think I would vote for Katie, but we'll see.
Catholic gamma, Delta.
Hi, all red hot. That's something that like,
that's like a term that most high was used.
Okay. So I'm an AOP, but you got to do the double eyes, but catcher,
if you ride out PI, they will catch them on with PI beta Phi. Here.
He move. If I move nice. Ooh,
there's an ADPi. Thank God. I was, I always chose ADPi as my fake sorority,
but thank God I didn't because Nicole would have just ripped me a new one.
Looks last Epsilon, new.
Loser class. Are you in like chapter? Okay.
So I'm in the gamma XY chapter Epsilon,
new alpha PSI chapter.
Okay. Okay. What?
This is so interesting. What?
Good. I feel like an opera now. Like I feel like they can,
they're going to stick me. Yeah.
How's your chapter found it?
I feel like this should be a pretty common question.
Everyone should know this in an org that you're in. So for instance,
five year is.
1852.
It's really all out on, I don't know the number. Exactly.
Uh.
Okay. So she means like the chapter.
Say some random random one 1895.
That seems okay. Here. Okay. This is,
I think like 1895. Isn't too far off from the numbers that they hit.
1892, 1851.
Well, I can't spell. We have six founders overall.
Was girls, girls, girls,
not answering my question. I freaked up, uh, out of this world.
What was my theme? What was my bid date? Theme? And they're like raced home.
This girl wants to go into the founders.
I hope we can just skip past that. Just move it to the side. Cause uh,
I'm just going to give a random, yeah.
It was breaking records.
I love what I did today. Okay.
Trying to try to not be a mole here. Like.
Well,
I didn't want to leave out the founder's question just cause I didn't want to
get anyone suspicious. So I brought it back in and I said that, uh, Mary, Mary,
Martha are the three founders of finding a sorority, which is very true.
It's on their, uh, buying you website.
Oh God. I made something up.
Hopefully they hopefully they didn't notice or see right through me.
What's everyone's philanthropy. Oh bet. Baby bed.
Oh, what does our philanthropy Ronald make dog food.
I give myself away on that one. Um.
Oh wait. Okay. She named him. She named him,
I think called me like three people said they're they're founders today.
Three Mary, Mary and Martha hundreds fricking killing this dude.
No one's going to suspect me. And if they do screw that stupid.
When people started talking about philanthropy,
all the other sorority girls were able to just, you know, type freely.
Whereas I was like having to think about it a little bit and it delayed my
answers.
I think my downfall was the founder's question. I think I survived that round.
Um, there were other girls who didn't talk that much.
I threw in some messages here and there.
I didn't want to take control of the chat too much.
I really had nobody to vote where like nobody said anything such,
but I think I'm going to go with Nikita. Sorry girl.
I just don't want to be the first one to like be voted out. To be honest,
I think I'm going to vote for.
Nicole. Definitely.
There's a lot of questions and I gotta be the person to ask questions that way.
I don't think it's me. Stephanie. She's an OB. I was so specific.
She gave them ammunition for them to go on to you.
I think I'm going to have to vote for Kate.
She might be the person to vote me out in that later rounds.
And I kind of just want to get the strongest personality.
Nicole seems a little stressed to me just cause like Ronald McDonald house
charities come on. And she said, I loved bid day. You want to be the mall?
I think I'm going to put Nikita. She didn't talk like a girl.
I guess I swear I did all this work. Get kicked out of me.
I'll be upset.
The three way tie Nicole Nikita and Stephanie,
you guys are going to have 30 seconds now to type out a paragraph which States
your case. You do not deserve to be voted out right now.
This is not good at all. This is not good. I am scared. I am.
So I love my sorority. I'm like, gosh,
I can't type when else I can't hold on. Not okay. I'm not,
there's no way I'm not getting out right now.
I think I should be kicked out.
So I screwed up. I screwed up so bad.
I said, I said, I'm a girl. Why did I say that? Honestly, I'm a girl.
All right.
So everyone other than them now gets a chance to read
vote.
Let's wait. I know they're all telling the truth, but if I had to pick one,
I thought was lying. Probably pick Nicole.
I'm still gonna vote for Stephanie. I was gonna be my downfall.
She stays in this competition. So Kate, when you watch this,
I think you're the strongest person in this chat.
And Stephanie has a garbage, garbage case. Also.
I'm a girl. I'm sorry. I'm sorry, Stephanie. You're probably really good person.
It was just really bad. All right.
So the first person voted out is going to be stuffing.
Hi Stephanie.
Everyone was, everyone was talking about why they joined the sorority.
I should have done that instead. I'm just talking about like, Oh,
I did everything correctly. And then to top it off, I say, and I'm a girl. Yeah.
I messed up big time. I folded under pressure. I cracked like a,
like a fragile, fragile, uh,
last, I don't know I was supposed to return home to my sorority after this.
Okay. So I know I answered it to fit. Uh, why didn't you rush to your sorority?
I got to think why. Um, okay,
so they're asking why they just wrote in, um,
I joined because I was on,
um,
my cheer team in high school and I
really wanted a sense of community and
support on such a large campus.
All right. So I'm going to drop a legacy car. How long do you want to send?
I got, so I'm going to say that.
Started talking like, all right, saying that rushed. Cause you know,
I love the girls made a huge connection with everybody and let's say,
let's say I have reading problems when I was little.
What are some of your favorite TG themes?
Let's just skip over that. So a TG is a theme gathering.
It's like when a fraternity pairs up with a sorority for a night and they like
have an event together.
You're coming in late. You're too late.
He's sniffing you out. Um, I wanna keep the contract ramping.
Y'all do lie.
All right. Big question. Can you all answer at once is one of my one,
my sorority friends told me they only wear white to initiation.
I mean, I could keep talking about our philanthropy, but okay.
Kate said big question. Can you all answer at once?
Okay. Thank you, Marcia. Um,
what color did you wear to initiation?
I don't know if she's talking about initiation or like just getting like pinned
in because they're two different things. And one of them is very secret,
which I have no clue.
The first you said white.
And then I was thinking that the rest of them were going to say white and that
was going to be the thing that they do across all sororities.
And then this girl said burden.
They're going to sniff the bus with both of us out.
Kay said every sorority here, whereas white, um.
I'm throwing all the suspect on Marsha and Nikita right now.
Okay. I'm not going to ask that big little reveal coming to clear so far. Oh.
Nikita Nikita says, Oh, we didn't have ours yet because of Corona.
But she said burgundy.
Everything already here wears white.
I saw some sororities on campus. Had designer brands.
The reveal thing. Oh no, I got no notes on that one.
They had designer brand big a little bit.
Okay. We have like one minute. Um, and nobody's really typing.
They asked big little reveal theme and I simply don't know the answer to that.
I don't even know what a big little reveal thing would be. Okay.
I'm just going to skip that question really quickly. Okay.
I think I'm good. I honestly think I'm doing really good right now.
Barbie. All right. I'm going to upperclassmen.
I had my big little reveal.
It just like I was cheating because I talked to my sorority friends like, Oh.
I said, where are using zoom? I totally missed type that.
Every story girl wears the white to their initiation. That's the thing.
How am I supposed to know that? I don't even have initiation.
I gonna go after Mikita just cause she,
she said the color of her initiation and then she's like, Oh wait,
we didn't have initiation.
I'm going to vote for Nikita. Just because she said burgundy.
For McKayla. Kate is Kate is speaking a lot.
She's being very specific nitpicky.
I don't like that because then they're going to sniff me out and she's going to
be asking the wrong questions. Unfortunately, Kate, you must be terminated.
I'm gonna be voting for Marsha because she was the only one that was said blue.
But I said Bernie. And he said,
it's probably going to be a tie between me and her.
Caitlin's really coming for our next though.
She said every sorority here wears white.
And I don't know if that's like a question or she was just really saying like,
you guys wore blue and burgundy, like liars. There's been another time.
It's between Nikita and Kate. Why am I going to be doing.
That's not good. What did I do? No please. No,
no, no. I thought I was doing so good.
Did I Alrighty up? Thank you guys.
Just because I feel like it keeps going. I get the boot.
I'm going to vote for Kate out now.
Why not? Yeah. I'm still gonna to. Okay.
All right. So I'm going to actually be voting for Kate this time. Our next.
Person eliminated is Katie.
Like basically I'm going to ask the questions you had hard times.
I promise you're laid low. The second round and then was sealed.
My fate is I couldn't type or think of anything for the life of me. I got,
I just got merged.
All right. We got three minutes. Um, I have a you,
but being put on a vote twice in a row is a scary.
Scary.
I'm gonna hit her with a low Mau Mau.
Um, what are you guys into? Marsha wants to know?
I'm asking good question too, because I already have what I'm going to say.
And then if they bring the competition somewhere else.
And make mood boards, my dance, my dance is a sorority thing.
At least it isn't Florida state. Hey, love to serve, make mood boards. Um,
what other quirky things.
Keep in mind the answer.
We don't sound like an idiot if they don't do this anywhere else,
I'm kind of screwed the pooch on that one. But.
So I'm going to ask if there's sororities a local or national a sorority.
This is actually a pretty big one. Oh.
We're just talking. Oh, I thought it was talking about hobbies.
Okay. UCS be I like to surf. That makes sense. Right.
Um, so basically now we're getting into the girl talk. Uh, Oh,
I guess it might just be a photo state thing. Okay.
So now they're just talking about line dancing. Yes, though.
She is literally two minutes from my apartment.
Yeah. Beauty. Oh,
okay. Yeah. The ocean flirty to miss my apartments,
but I want the little twinkly lights. Um, or the, I don't know what the star.
The hashtag.
Like my typing style is good. I've gone to.
And try to plan to this one just because I asked the question and we're kind of
rolling on now about just girl talk. I.
I seem so legit right now. So legit. I love this,
these mutual connections that I have.
Let's go with Georgia, Georgia.
Bro. I can't spell what's going on wrong. What's your initiation.
I'm going to say, Ooh.
It's so hard to type on my laptop with long nails.
Say, I'm going to say girl, I feel your pain.
Keep having, Oh my gosh.
I can't having to retype everything.
Ours is a long process. It was moved.
We're talking about nails. I don't know. I ignored though.
This initiation question could hurt me,
but I'm going to wait. Okay.
Yeah. All right.
Let's say you want to process it has moved through the virtual platform halfway.
I said, I almost broke a nail the other day.
I got so frustrated when I was typing my essay.
The charts thing is what stuck out to me. It's like workout group, all girls.
Oh, regular dude would not know about that. Me and Mikayla were homeys.
Cause uh.
You know, Todd jump charge up. Let's do it.
Everyone's suspicious of her already would probably just going to vote for
Nikita. I'm going to go with Nikita. I think if we got her out this round,
we might just conclude the game and say, you know what? No more moles.
I believe you guys Nikita.
Is going to be gone only because the last two rounds.
We were suspicious. I think it was Rachel.
It's less suspicious then because she did line dancing.
I started I'm voted out during prep.
The person voted out is it. Um,
I have a terrible bowl.
I was already put on the spot literally twice if you're put on the spot.
And like everyone else was like incentivized to like, you know, go for all that.
I am satisfied with the fact that like I passed two rounds.
Give me a thumbs up. If you want to continue and a thumbs down,
if you think you've caused them all in one to end the game now. Okay.
Majority thumbs down, thumbs down. Oh my God. Right?
Let's go. I am so sorry.
Y'all they're about to be mad. Oh man. I can't believe,
I didn't even think I was going to win it.
Whoever's the mall reveal when you feel ready to do so
nice.
[Inaudible] dude, everyone's a dude.
Are you all in a fraternity?
Kappa Sigma, California, Krono, mega chapter five side of this.
So I'm in Phi Delta Epsilon pre-medical fraternity.
I thought it'd be really cool for me to join them.
Cause like I'm in a coed fraternity. So like, you know, boys, girls.
Who was the person who said, I'm a girl
that I mess up big time. I was like, I'm a girl.
So I thought it made sense in my mind. I was like, wow.
A girl is really trying to get away with that. Well,
you guys are all gonna get 50 bucks as a
[inaudible]. I need that money for rent.
There's been a ton of people asking for this episode for a while. Yeah.
I like, I always see those in like comments and I'm like, Oh.
Okay. Definitely hella good.
All right guys. Take care. All right. Thanks guys.
I have no words. I have no words. I'm so mad. I don't.
We were all surprised. We were all. We do not expect this whatsoever.
Y'all in the comments pile. You're like how'd you not be there as a yet?
Awesome. Tik TOK, famous. Steve wears pants. Follow me.
Shameless plug moral of the story. Men are trash.